[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay oh there's some bees in pop allows
you to be the voice for the voices when
I met Isaiah I didn't know what to
expect once had an opportunity to
communicate with him I was like now he
can he can talk he can talk he has no
problem talking let's be ground I was
wanting in the Songhai
when I think of Isaiah as an artist or
more so feel that he's a poet
he's writing poetry he's talking about
his experiences I don't care what people
think of me
Friday on earth they carry me jump gone
but I let myself like a lighter to my
family my first record that Isaiah I did
was oxygen to fly he wrote it always the
voice it's a challenge to be someone
else's voice but Isaiah has so many
things that he wants to say we find a
way to make it work yeah yeah okay
wouldn't it next with you we could work
on the second verse for I worked with
Isaiah I had a heavy presence in the
local scene as far as rap music as well
as some community work all right we're
gonna take it from the top
okay we were able to come together and
kind of amplify our message and that's
just that you shouldn't stand to the
side and do nothing
if you're fully capable of doing
something I brought out a special guest
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
in any different mall Cuddy on the road
had to do some different things up with
the family all from matific
[Music]
and if you need I probably have if I
don't have it I can get a fit in 24
hours
hurry up and you have a video shoot you
neither shoes coming out in two weeks I
just have to make a call and I'll get it
for you
[Music]
every day millions of people tuned to DJ
Khaled snapchat the key to more success
one of my favorite DJ kala pearance is
is this kid Ben how's business in a new
year oh I see you he's 16 years old and
he's at the helm of a burgeoning sneaker
empire when he says has done nearly a
million dollars in business and boasts
clients like DJ Cod and Chris Brown meet
this sneaker Don so my name is Benjamin
capitalistic people call me Benjamin
cakes but most you guys know me as a
sneaker Don school ends at 3 o'clock I
get home outlook for you dinner do some
homework and go straight to the office
space and like any good Don family's
important I'm his manager so if you need
anything call me
ok not that family I'm the mother of the
sneaker Don to me he's my little boy but
I also see a business and he had a goal
he's self driven he's motivated he's a
hard worker the great Don's they say
come from humble beginnings the first
pair of sneakers actually got me a game
I was in fifth grade the Galaxy pack
came out and I got the LeBrons
gotta love sneakers after that probably
around sixth grade when my parents
didn't want to fund my sneaker hobby
anymore I just figure out a way how to
get the money for it and then I realized
if I buy five or ten pairs by paying
people to stand in line for me I could
sell it to a larger clientele and make
more money plus get my shoe for free and
then it just finally broke through and
the money you started coming in that
first it amazed me how sneakers can go
for like so much money for like one shoe
people were charging a thousand I
thought it was a good joke or something
I was in dollars but hey that's why he's
the sneaker Don so what comes next
really excited to open up a physical
store the first of all case doesn't mean
Miami then I'm trying to LA New York and
Chicago all my friends when they dropped
out of sneak game they're like it's dead
it's over there's no more like you're
not getting on their thing you're
wasting your time
money not about what was true play
themselves indeed they did sneaker Don
indeed they did
[Music]
speedo callousness
[Music]
what is this
do you say this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if I am their queen up there they saw
her she met master science I know tanjo
vino - gimme a single-car thought I did
not say that
you know ma Tarkanian up my company
autonomy Matta kumarkan Iona as do it
for the other children doctor no there
cuz it kidding me right no missing the
tech we can use customers so you know
mano a tight mo mata tirtha no sato
through channels to stay because Cordova
dakedo good I know you don't not it
cannot be you know me katie fernstaedt
oh dear so much you know step relief
city Solana Hayashi notice in it after
that too you know de Soto Cano tiny
without actually
for the three among Canadian experiment
ranging the power down post cannot even
or still show up today is suing you know
technical a Circassian engine I cannot
only must met
Kumud a couple walls there yet his god
amon-ra single drive up you know a
company nakatome or see what occurs to
you will not go to morality but was hit
by ons root a key to the cute kitty yo
te ayudo vinegar imitate occur sooner
written yesterday she utter a poem I
wrote it so reverse rejection no Cara
Cano severity Oni esquina Pato so Jamie
articulate ANOVA keyboard sure I am ever
to harnessing and go to each
assertiveness
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and you have Attila go where shall I
kiss oh my gosh McGavin and shame
Michael - beam exposure to the thoughts
and yeah does not salute very slam
mobile odd we have had really Elizabeth
yeah my smart today that might feel more
healthy only solitary star from Aquila
humid after da hai jaan shame shall I
read when listen initially Shalom Kurumi
Sasha fix Anna Boch ricin Anna GABA
Madhava ocean I'm whenever Cobra
Nocturna Goomba vacation Sarah demonym
la Habana smear and I'm Robert assassin
a second father to whom I done oh cool
it harder for listening
vermicelli Shannon
yesh moach a melody much I would like to
tell Michelle Pfeiffer Temecula liquor
Kashmiri Pandits the share the Macomb
allow McGee Melvin Vernell hot lava
ocean I know in Malibu align the
aluminum and copper sheets Bellingham
shaken LA lawyer emotional detection II
of shame - shame shame shame on of a
variation be bleached enough no new team
push 11 phenom radish Mahajan onion
manaphy riddle wanna feed a log not a
warm welcome aboard
yahood barach on higher and higher tone
Masseria back on hiya tom when muslimeen
back on Hayatou shinji mikami maquila if
shoulders at like here and machine
machine very pitiful am teaming him up
oh c'mon fear has affiliate habits
affiliate or do know about funa a lovely
tenía la funa
are the island teeny allah so teeny
Rebecca de Lima game retina machine was
a Magnuson a hottie with a machinima
shisha shallots in the ocean and shame
Elena rather conflict right after school
I just like China like one to the gym so
I can climb
[Music]
it's a dangerous right but I only think
that I'm afraid of is not being able to
get those ovens
[Music]
with climbing I don't think that it
really matters with how big you are
if you're smaller you can hold on longer
and your hands might be small ways so it
can fit my finger it's on hold
I started climbing in Central Park when
I was six years old now I don't think I
can like live without it
[Music]
when you're close to the top of the
climb you're trying to do your funds
usually feel like they're gonna explode
and they're gonna like first open and
you feel like you have to let go but
with climbing you just can't let go I
think that climbing is it's obviously a
sport it's also like a dance you sort of
have to be able to like flow up the wall
and come up with your own techniques to
get to accomplish I think people shocked
if I do something that they can't do
something because I'm still really young
and I'm a girl so like doing something
that even if a guy can't do is pretty
special
[Music]